in the lobby of Ramsey solutions on the
brand-new debt-free scream stage they're
here grant and Michelle or with us hey
guys how are you hi Dave
welcome welcome where do you guys live
Memphis Tennessee well welcome
appreciate you coming up to Nashville
very fun how much debt of you guys paid
off $40,000 all right how long did this
take you two years and six days haha I
love it
fairly precise and your range of income
during that two years in six days
started at fifty-six thousand ended at
fifty-six thousand there you go
all right what do you guys do for a
living I'm a police officer in Memphis
okay and I'm a stay-at-home mom bond
with our two boys yeah very cool well
thank you for serving your community sir
thank you I appreciate it all right neat
stuff huh what kind of debt was the
forty thousand good old student loan
debt time to get rid of Sallie Mae got
to kick the old woman out of the house
Navy into Nelnet I love it very fun good
for you guys
so what happened two years and six days
ago that put you on this journey before
we began our journey
I experienced a pretty significant
mental health crisis some of it was tied
to my job but I can't I can't blame it
on my jobs not my jobs fault so there
was anxiety there was depression there
you know a pretty long bout with
suicidal thoughts had to take six weeks
off for therapy once we got that we knew
that something needed to be different we
knew we wanted to change as a family we
knew we wanted a house but the biggest
obstacle to that was the student loan
debt hmm so about six months after I
took six weeks off I was able to change
shifts to work in the night shift
I always alpha if you're listening that
allowed us to go to the financial peace
classes that our church River City
Church in Bartlett offered we made all
the classes together we started about I
think the second class was when we
officially started counting our debt
snowball two years six days we got it
done Wow
so how you doing yourself two years in
six days later I'm a lot healthier good
he's like a different guy yeah okay
there is something uh connected and I
I'm don't I'm not a mental health
professional I don't know anything about
but there's something connected with oh
and traction moving forward towards a
goal that I believe I'm gonna be able to
hit that that that walks someone through
what you've been through and the money
piece sometimes can be a place that you
get a hold of something you go okay this
is a it's a victory I can have it's a
very it's a very tangible victory
sometimes it's terrible sometimes it's
unpleasant sometimes you know you'd
rather drag your face across concrete
yeah yeah but it's so incredibly
necessary particularly when you're able
to overcome that this is just ones and
zeroes it's not just ones and zeroes
there's got to be a there's got to be a
meaning and a purpose more fundamental
in deeper than the ones and zeros oh
yeah you won't do it if you don't know
it's too hard much do you have to have a
why and in your case you were you know
it became the tail end of a healing
story is what amounts to that's what I'm
hearing
yeah yeah well congratulations man thank
you Dave I'm proud of you
thank you fought off a lot more
important stuff than debt here
definitely yeah and and got rid of some
debt too by the way very very good so
what do you tell people the the key to
getting out of debt is there has to be
something foundational to there has to
be a there has to be a meaning there has
to be a y-you know
Frederick Nietzsche said he who has a
why can bear almost any how and for us
it was the latching on to changing
crooked paths changing things that had
been damaged renewing things that had
been broken putting back together things
that had been torn to pieces and cutting
off a lot of Deadwood
and at the same time building something
new because the debt was our biggest
obstacle to a home so we we were able to
buy our first home after we got rid of
the student loan debt we have two
beautiful boys at home Noah and Jude who
don't have to have this particular piece
be part of their legacy so I I can't I
can't walk away from this because I'm
pretty sure if I read write today is
National Suicide Prevention day and I
don't I don't believe in coincidences
and we lost a pastor friend of ours
yesterday nationally internationally and
to that and I've lost three friends to
that this year I'm sorry and so you
don't you told us the key of how you get
out of debt what do you think the keys
were to your recovering and moving away
from that depression what were the
things people gave you as they retrains
your brain to move forward you mean what
would you tell somebody out there that's
listening right now regarding your own
personal power two things one invest
your power in your strength and your
efficacy in the places that you can have
the greatest contribution and most of
the time that's not going to be some
great cause out in the world it's going
to be you and your own personal
transformation and the people that are
closest to you yeah so on the one hand
you're powerless to affect anyone else
and make them do what you might do if
you were in their shoes my personality I
tend to over empathize with other people
mm-hmm and part of that is good but the
other side of that sword is I tend to
overestimate my own ability to bring
about the change that I would like to
see in their lives you know while at the
same time since I'm focusing so much of
my effort out of that direction I it it
left me drained tranquil to me yeah to
be a better husband and a better father
so once I started realizing to
relinquish
control of things that I had no business
trying to control anyhow and putting my
money in my own bank as it were how
you're preaching that way to the choir
no doubt that was where I realized I
could bring about the most change in and
do the most good
yeah was in narrowing my focus
eliminating things that weren't
essential and focusing on home and
because a certain portion of depression
is often that the sense of powerlessness
that I can't get unstuck and you can't
get unstuck when you're all your gas is
out of your tank because you poured it
out all the time that's what you're
saying and you and you you're not you're
not stuck there do you have you the
traction you guys have had in your lives
and the $40,000 is just that that's just
them that's just the gravy on the
biscuit on your story man you got a
great story God's been good to you thank
you Dave yeah probably the scariest part
for me personally through this was that
because I'm a stay-at-home mom I didn't
contribute financially to the debt being
paid off I had to pick up slack at home
and also because his job was such a
catalyst with his mental health issues
that fear that as he worked overtime
that he would you know get back into
really day he would relapse he would get
back into those wrong ways of thinking
and and stuff and so my perseverance was
a much quieter perseverance I had to
trust that God was going to keep him
balanced and also I was there going this
isn't this isn't a race
there's nobody is putting a you know a
stopwatch on us or anything like let's
just keep going you know one step at a
time it was a marathon yeah he's more of
a sprinter and I'm more of a slow go ER
and so we kind of balanced each other
yeah I kind of suspected that all right
you guys are special what a great story
so proud of y'all Thank You volkens book
for you everyday millionaires that is
the next chapter in your story that's
the next thing down the pike this is
just the beginning the things are gonna
go from here or absolutely gonna be
incredible for y'all I can see it very
very clearly well done y'all are
it's grant and Michelle Memphis
Tennessee $40,000 paid off in two years
and six days making 56,000 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
[Applause]